today is a pretty important day here at
the Conan show as I mentioned several
months ago we are marking our 25th year
on the air we thought we'd mark our 20
because you're on the air by changing up
our format so today is going to be our
last hour-long program and soon in
January we're gonna switch to a half
hour now Oh trust me it's gonna be
better we did some testing and people
are like little essay him would be great
no I'm gonna I'm going to half an hour
so I can spend more time on the things I
really love I'm not talking about my
wife and children that ship sailed a
long time ago
no I'm talking about travel shows around
the world silly remote pieces
interviewing really interesting people
really just focusing on the stuff that
we love the most now to make this switch
our show is going on a brief hiatus now
before you get all excited and think
we're getting a break from Conan
remember that nothing nothing could be
further from the truth this fall I'm
literally going to be everywhere check
it out first this is all true I will be
launching an 18 city tour of America
titled Team Coco presents Conan and
Friends an evening of stand-up and
investment tips all right
this is it's gonna be a show where I
personally are gonna be meeting with as
many of you out there as possible and
introducing you to some of my favorite
stand-up comedians at these shows you
will be allowed to touch me you'll be
encouraged to smell me and for a small
fee you can take me home okay you'd be
shocked how little that costs that tour
I believe it's in 18 city tours and the
rhf HTT tour starts November 2nd and it
visits these cities so check them out
see if you're in there something that
went a little faster than I thought
anyway for tickets go to team koco.com
slash tour ok second I'll be launching a
podcast in November called Conan O'Brien
needs a prank
all right I already started taping the
podcast and having a lot of fun I think
you're going to enjoy it you can listen
to the teaser and subscribe to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend for free by going
to Apple podcast.com slash team Coco if
you just want to check it out third if
you enjoy it when I visit other
countries and make an ass of myself
check out our next travel special called
Conan in Japan that's
now I had an amazing time in that
country it's gonna be a terrific episode
I believe Conan in Japan airs Wednesday
November 28th at 10 o'clock p.m. fourth
that's right there's more fourth it's
like an infomercial to help celebrate my
25 years on the air early next year
we're launching a new state-of-the-art
website called Conan 25 this site yeah
you're applauding it you literally don't
know what it means
25 seconds till everyone's dead this
site will contain literally thousands of
digitally remastered episodes from my
entire late-night career starting in
1993 up to the present and having all
these shows together on one really
beautifully curated site has been a
dream of mine for a long long time so
just think if you saw a sketch from our
old late-night show while eating ramen
in your dorm room in 1985 a sketch that
either delighted or enraged you now you
can relive that moment anytime you want
okay so that's gonna be pretty cool
we're looking forward to that while I'm
doing all this stuff the next few months
I'm going to be constantly checking in
on social media if you want to see what
I'm up to if I'm dressed undressed you
can check me out on Twitter at Conan
O'Brien Instagram at Team Coco and
facebook.com slash Team Coco arguably
two months
let's team up yeah in other words I'm
gonna be a major part of your life for
the next few months and there's really
nothing you can do about it then I'm
gonna return in January with a new
format and some radical cosmetic surgery
I'm talking I'm getting a lot of work
done take a look at this rendering by my
plastic surgeon I think you'll be
impressed now that's that's worth taking
a break for store I'm excited about all
this change and by the sound of your
response to this applause sign I can
tell that you are too
[Applause]
you